[Music]
welcome back to Hannity joining us now
with reaction to the latest controversy
swirling around Robert Malloy's team is
the author of the book trumped up how
criminalization of political differences
and dangers democracy Alan Dershowitz
all right good evening professor
Dershowitz it's good to have you here
tonight now
you wrote a fascinating article saying
that Trump doesn't need to fire Muller
and you say that there are certain
tactics that can be used that are almost
better than actually firing him talk
talk to us well I learned about this
from Red Auerbach the great coach of the
Boston Celtics who told me one day when
we were sitting at a Celtics game that
whenever he used to scream at an
official and yell at the official he'd
always get the next call in his favor
then I heard the same thing from
baseball player who said when he
protested a ball or a strike he would
get the next call I think that's the
tactic that's being used here you
continuously attack Muller you bring up
every possible issue whether it be
conflict of interest hiring the wrong
people failing to get a warrant for the
emails using the dossier to get the
national security warrant and Mullah
who's so concerned about his integrity
and his reputation may very well be
inclined to lean over backwards to show
his fairness and to make a close call in
favor of Trump rather than against Trump
so I suspect that's probably what's
happening there playing the ref says
it's called in sports well you know
aside from that from the from the
baseball analogies I mean you're you're
an attorney you understand that there
are rules there are guidelines we were
talking about this in the other block if
you have possession of documents as a
lawyer that is privileged
it contains privileged information then
you are ethically obligated to at least
notify the person whose information you
have and yet and most team knows all
this are they playing by the rules are
they just hurting themselves here well
they're claiming that they have these
thousands of emails and they haven't
even gone through them yet to determine
whether any of them are privileged
they're also taking the position that
nothing is privileged because everybody
was on notice that this was the
possession of the government the
property of the government not the
property of individual
but that violates core notions of civil
liberties people have reasonable
expectations of privacy they don't
expect that their emails to their lawyer
well the emails to the future President
of the United States the president-elect
would be looked into without a subpoena
or a search warrant and it was so easy
from Muller to go and get a search
warrant used to be a judge you know you
just go to a judge make any kind of
plausible presentation you get your
search warrant why not do it he's been
conducting a very sloppy investigation
when you're going after the president
you can't afford to be sloppy because
you know that there are going to be
people taking advantage of every mistake
you make and he's made too many and you
know professor when you talk about you
know the dot-gov and no expectation of
privacy this this presidential
transition team there are statutes that
apply to them in particular regulations
memos of understanding so I can get the
you know you have no expectation of
privacy on certain servers gov but this
is surrounded by particular legislation
and regulations and mo members of
understanding and it's outrageous Mike I
think it's out of course okay let me
tell you the hype the hypocrisy you have
people on the other side making the
following two arguments
number one they say that of course they
can't be any privileged because he
wasn't a government official he wasn't
the president yet so they can't be
executive privilege on the other hand
they say he they were public officials
for purposes of being able to get the
emails you can't have it both ways you
have to pick a theory and they're
inconsistent well you have to pick a
theory but you know in addition to that
I think what we've seen with Muller is
with this whole thing with Peter struck
and you know the woman with whom he was
having the affair Lisa page and work for
the FBI and they're talking about you
know they're gonna have to get an
insurance policy and you know they have
this meeting at around the same time
struck who's in charge of
counterintelligence that we start this
Russia probe on the alleged Trump Russia
collusion and Muller doesn't say
anything about struck and the
realization that he found out that there
were all of this anti Trump sentiment I
mean it's
it's hard he did he did he did get rid
of them on the other hand secret he did
it no no he did it as soon as he found
out about it but he didn't tell the
public right until months later as a
result of a lawsuit brought by a group
of lawyers so look I think I think
Muller is a decent and honorable man who
cares deeply about his reputation is
trying to do the right thing he made a
terrible mistake when you're going after
the president who's a Republican I know
who was a Republican you take much more
care and who you put on the
investigative team you make sure that
it's Caesar's wife everybody has to be
above reproach he didn't pass the
seasons wife test now he's being
careless in obtaining evidence without
warrants or subpoenas those play right
into the hands of the Trump team and
there's just no good reason why a good
lawyer should do that I would know about
somebody working for me to do anything
like that nobody working for me would do
it but it's bullying and don't you think
it's interesting though how the
president's team is handling it you know
they're not really going full-bore on
this one I think that the facts speak
for themselves and by the way you know
you say that he's made one or two errors
I think he made an error right from the
get-go the fact that he applied for the
job to be the head of the FBI and and
and didn't get it the fact that he's so
tight with Jim called me and as you know
the two of them have think they've made
history together when John Ashcroft was
in the hospital I mean that is classic
conflict of interest you know it
professor admit it well I think I think
that the very idea of appointing a
special prosecutor defeated the purpose
of any inquiry we want an open public
inquiry a bipartisan inquiry to make
sure the Russians never intrude on an
American election and tell what we get
instead what we get is behind closed
doors grand jury we're never gonna learn
anything everybody is yelling lock him
up lock her up that's not the way to
proceed we shouldn't be criminalizing
political differences we should be
gathering information from every side
this was a terrible election it was
election filled with problems and we
oughta use it as a lesson to avoid
problems like this in the future and the
special counsel is the worst
hearing you say that even if if in all
of these open processes we we find that
the law is violated we don't prosecute
people I know if if you you've used the
criminal law last not first when you
appoint a special counsel what you're
saying is we know that what crimes
committed now let's find out what crimes
they were Stalin talking to Lavrentiy
Beria and Barrie is saying show me the
man and I'll find you the crime that's
not the way America should work we
should first do an investigation an
open-ended nonpartisan 9/11 type
investigation why only proof or allowed
to go to the Intelligence Committee we
have no idea he's the guy whose wife
work for food fusion GPS on the
anti-trump dossier and then he has a
meeting with fusion after they lose the
election and I can only conclude I mean
that you know they're gonna try to get
their story straight I mean this that
doesn't help either
well everybody should we should look
into all of these issues to avoid
recurrence in the future we have to
clean up our election system and we
shouldn't do it through a special
Council somebody before mentioned that
the Muellers should appoint a an ethics
consultant I had proposed that in my
article this morning I even named David
Souter is once this person that would
help him at least avoid these problems
in the future
look the Trump people would rather see
him have ethical problems because it
gives them ammunition it's in truck it's
in mowers interest to clean up his act
and go forward smoothly it's a little
late in the game I think he's lost all
credibility book professor thanks so
much for being with us